[music]
Tormasova came out, they wanted their low,
just but apple juice,
and expressed need, then the
heroism of our inter-ends, such without
zbroy, then shots of a live lancer with a
length of more than a kilometer and let
loose and turn the technique, then a lesson on the territory of the
bowl, let him be glad
that you will give me shooting nima
nothing let's what is your
freaking brothers let's
[applause]
oh and here you are all I'm not ukraine [music] I'm spitting with teal sohu heroically we are peaceful
and the mouse the theme of konotop bashtanka energy dar
near poplar moths other places of forces in ukraine
yaks are not allowed  occupiers covering the
mps and cover a little more expensive people go out
in front of arming the equipment shop extremely
nonchalant I action husbands
[applause]